hello folks welcome to rational science
today i'm not feeling good again i'm
having uh problems with my chest
uh
i have to deep uh breathe deeply i don't
know why
i go to the hospital go to the doctor
and they tell me you're okay bill
pressure's good uh heart is good blood
is good
and it's like you know you go to the
doctor
and you tell them i don't feel good
doctor no you feel okay go home
you end up in the morgue
or you go to the doctor and you say i'm
i'm doing fine i'm i'm doing okay and he
says
no no you got to take this pill
why i'm doing okay
well because the
people who want me to peddle this pill
says that it's good for you
so uh you know
you wonder about all these witch doctors
anyways i had some well wishers and i
want to thank them okay here's a couple
of them i pulled a few of the comments
people made
and phil says there leave carbohydrates
and beers alone beers he wants me to
leave
here i've been drinking a beer i mean if
i'm gonna die here on camera i might as
well you know have a beer
die with a beer in my hand anyways it
says concentrate on cooked and raw
vegetables a lot of people recommend
that no fruits at all
some people do recommend fruits others
say no okay careful with physical
exercise slow and well yeah i do my
exercise you can see there
always do your exercises
uh
so yeah people everybody's uh
involved
with this issue about um
you know doing exercise eating veggies
let go of the carbos you know carbs
and the um maybe even some people say
let go of the meats you know
everybody's an expert today on how to be
healthy
and
you know
in my case
i'm uh 69
going down a hundred and the issue is uh
whether you can do miracles
after a certain age
you know when uh when you're 69
your life is behind you
and you're talking about history when
you're 20 it's the other way around
you're looking at the future
your life is ahead of you you know so uh
there's different ways of looking at
these things in fact that's i think has
a bearing
on what uh how uh people visualize
extinction
because you know the old folks like me
older folks that i've got there's people
with much older than me you know and
their their their life is really their
history they've they've got it all here
in memory
whereas the
person who's 20 or 30 years old you know
he looks forward and he says you know i
don't want to die i don't want the world
to end now
i want to retire reach
old age
and then die naturally or not die at all
if possible and then if extinction
happens after me i mean i don't care
yeah but see so those are two different
ways of looking at this whole thing in
fact some people said bill the reason
you think about extinction is because
you're about to die
and yeah it could be true i'm not saying
that's not true um i'm looking at the
mechanism okay i'm saying uh what the
mechanism of extinction is not worried
about when it's going to happen okay
well another foul said here um
it may advise that you look into having
one small aspirin per day
until you have more data to set on and
pursue either coronary artery calcium or
measurements so that you have actionable
data to act on together with your doctor
uh what i can tell you is um you know uh
my mother always said that
she didn't like doctors and she faked
just about all our
vaccines i don't even know what vaccines
i got because she faked a lot of them
she did not believe in vaccines she
worked at the swedish american hospital
as a nurse
for a couple years then she worked
as a dentist assistant and she thought a
lot of the procedures that she saw right
were unnecessary that they were for
profit
and so she developed
a militant act attitude against doctors
in general
and the flip side of that is that
she died because of
cancer to the uterus she died at a
relatively young age of 62 and she could
have lived maybe another 20 years
if she would have caught it on time knew
what it was and would have had an
operation an operation a lot of women
have today which is just get get rid of
the uterus and you can live a lot a
little longer
and so you know you got to be careful
about what decisions you take you know
and uh for me it's a lesson
you know i hope you take it as a lesson
but uh regarding aspirin she she
believed in aspirins and one of the
things i can tell you is that i believe
in aspirin too i'm a strong proponent of
aspirin because you know when you drink
a little too much usually that's that's
the case when i take an aspirin you know
the next day if you don't take an
aspirin you're going to feel very bad
and to help with the hangover
i usually
learn from one of my buddies at work
that you know it's good to take an
aspirin at night especially if you drink
take an aspirin and then go to sleep
you'll wake up a lot better
and i followed his advice and it's
always worked for me
so i can recommend that aspirin
is i i believe in aspirin i don't know
if i believe in the vax and the cohen
but i do believe in aspirin okay so yeah
uh you don't have to tell me uh when i
especially when i'm overdoing it with
the drinks okay
and yeah if i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
with a beer in my hand okay
uh you know you gotta put those uh
aspirin pills down with beer
okay if elsa please look up coronary
artery calcification
score regarding your health issues if
you want to live a bit
more ditch the sugars carbs and get
control of your insulin levels you can
look up insulin resistance etc etc
yeah
one of the issues there is that today
everybody is an expert
in health okay why because there's so
much information out there
and a lot of it depends on what side you
take you know there are studies that
contradict each other or there are
opinions out there
and people say oh they proved this well
the other guy proved the opposite you
know and so the question who are you
going to follow and it's whatever your
original or what you
already believe that takes you in one
direction or the other you know so i
don't know i can't tell you i'm not an
expert in health
i do have arthritis i've had it since
the age of around 38 that's when i first
noticed that i had some kind of pain due
to
joints
and that was 31 years ago and today yeah
i feel a lot more uh pain in the
muscles in the uh joints
i've had several operations uh three of
them on the shoulders two on the knees
uh and so on you know micro surgeries
you know to fix some little thing
fortunately we have that today uh you
know i can't imagine plural neanderthal
when he had arthritis he had to die with
it but today you can do a little bit
about that with some operations and
people say well you didn't need that
operation you could have done this this
and that yeah i mean you know uh
at one point in time i could you know do
the hitler salute i couldn't raise my
arm
because my arm just hurt so much and uh
they did the operation a few months
later i was okay
so i don't know what to tell you it's
like thank god we live in this day and
night where they cure these problems but
i'm not an expert on the issue okay
okay uh another subject matter that came
out this week
ocean
city topless ordinance head to the
supreme court the latest legal battle
the women want to take it off okay
they want to show their breasts just
like men do and i'm all for it
i i in fact i think it should be
mandatory all women should be topless
and
at the beach okay and uh
maybe even bottomless i mean it's up to
them i have no problem with one way or
another of course my wife will blacken
my eyes if she sees me watching or
staring at one of them
but yeah
women try to imitate men in this day and
age a lot of them think it's a question
of rights
and
men kind of look at that in a different
way they say you know
yeah sure go ahead show whatever you've
got
of course if the woman is 100 years old
you may not want to watch you know
so everybody has their own vision on
this okay we'll see what the supreme
court decides
anyway another matter russia vetoes u.n
resolution on climate change as global
security threat
and i think you should keep this in mind
because
uh you know for those of you who believe
in conspiracies and so on that they're
the rich are governing uh the poor and
so on corralling them and you know
manipulating them and so on here you
have mr putin and he thinks that this is
something that favors the united states
that's got nothing to do with the
climate
and it's got nothing to do with uh
security threat global security threat
they think it's got to do with business
and that the united states is trying to
take advantage of that somehow and you
know creating this hullabaloo about oh
climate change we got to fix it because
otherwise we're gonna die
and you know my version on that is that
um
you know climate change is so slow
we'll never get to it does climate
change yeah it's always changed uh 600
million years that we've been around you
know life has been around
um
it's uh climate has changed every day of
of our lives of in life's history
and uh
does that kill us does that cause
extinction
no obviously not
uh you know climate change change if
anything helps out the animals that are
gonna radiate in the next generation
that's when you know certain animals uh
squat some niches out there and they
grow big and whatever numerous
and others that are not favored by the
climate or the plants that are favored
by the climates
they stay behind and so you have the
rich and powerful and you have the weak
and uh
and sometimes numerous
so
you know climate change does not cause
extinction and if you look at a lot of
the theories of extinction that you'll
read out there they're all related to
climate or it was the oxygen cycle there
was the carbon cycle it was the nitrogen
cycle
it's got nothing to do with it
absolutely nothing to do with it
neither neither climate change nor
asteroids ever caused the extinction of
a single species on earth
and but that's what the paleontologists
believe because it happens so suddenly
they say it must have been this
had it been a catastrophic accident
and no
mother nature i believe works in a
different way and she uses the same
cookie cutter for all mass extinctions
okay
okay um
paul says uh
that all these countries that i talked
about the other day the fact that iran
cuba and so on they wouldn't go along
with this kogit thing because they're
enemies of the united states and if
kogit was created by the united states
or even perhaps china right
um
done by the rich to control the poor is
that what it's all about
and israel says you have just
missed uh what country like usa mexico
brazil russia china you know what they
have in common and
they say it's the international
financial system
yeah i don't think uh unless you clarify
exactly what
you're referring to i don't think we can
say that
this uh thing this covet thing has to do
with some kind of
manipulation at least
i'm not convinced of that
you know you can shoot all kinds of
theories out there
but you know i i personally don't buy
them i think that there is a bug out
there some people are probably dying as
a result of that i have no idea
i know no person
uh that is that i'm in contact with you
know that had died
you know i heard by sec by word of mouth
only that someone over there died
and he know who knows if they died
because of kobe you know my brother died
this year one of them um died earlier
this year he died of
diabetes
and
you know
maybe
the government with the record that he
died because of code
because you know there's a lot of
interest in that jacking up the numbers
and so on
so there's a lot of that that's human
nature to do stuff like that
did they did he die of covet maybe you
know i mean if you look up the record
man maybe that's what it says
so i wouldn't put it past them that they
say well he died of coke
and you know we know what what he died
of so i don't know if they're
manipulating the data or
or what out there
personally i don't care i don't give a
damn about all that stuff uh i'm not
into this kobe if i got to get the vacs
i get the backs only because i gotta
travel and uh i don't care about getting
it or not getting it either way
for me it's the same
if i get the the bug
if there is a bug and i get the bug and
i die because of the bug well so be it i
mean
that's life you know
okay uh here we have another fella says
uh the rich ruled the world it's always
been like that and he said well
technically there were no rich people
for most of human history
hunter-gatherer tribes don't have no
filthy rich people
the communist dream is to somehow revive
the social relations seen in primitive
tribes
and i think the kefal is right you know
i pretty much uh subscribed to this
notion yeah the uh people in the old
days
uh they had no rich people i mean hunter
gatherers and so on
when we talk about uh rich people we're
talking about you know
from commercial agriculture
maybe
the neolithic you know up onwards
anything beyond the neolithic the
paleolithic you know you're not talking
about rich people obviously you know
because there were they had no property
property had not been invented yet the
only property was the land that the clan
hunted in they said this is my property
and anyone who steps over here i'm gonna
kill him
he's gonna be part of my food my uh my
supper
okay another fella along the same lines
says it is survival of the fittest
always has been always will be the rich
are just manipulating the process of
natural selection
it's these are opinions and the question
is you know you can't just give an
opinion here we try to do uh
science science is about explanations
not about opinions
and so it'd be nice if you put a little
more like saying if you don't accept
uh natural selection
you say that never happened i don't
believe in it or whatever fine
what do you propose in exchange how do
we get here why do we have uh all these
animals why are some
herbivores and others carnivores uh and
some and we're all mammals you know the
cow is a mammal the lion's a mammal and
one is a herbivore and the other one's a
carnivore you gotta explain
that's the purpose of science but to
give an opinion because you know this
what you believe in
doesn't tell us much so you know it's
people like to spin their wheels
uh give me a theory something i can sink
my think
my teeth into something that i can
understand not that i believe but that i
understand okay
okay along the same lines for all says
let me put over here
diversity reminds me of the democracy
you refer to an illusion it appears to
be
yeah democracies never happen in fact
another fellow here says along this or
maybe i think it's the same i don't know
uh never be democracy yeah yeah you know
plato uh he he said that it's the rule
of the mob
and he didn't like democracy he said it
was the worst form of government because
you got people who have no stake in it
people who are ignorant
people who have no idea about anything
and they're going to rule you're going
to put them up there
which is more or less what marx
suggested mark said hey you know let's
put the
workers up there and let them govern
because it's their personal
interests i got something here what is
this
it's their personal interest but at the
same time the question is if the guy is
an ignorant person
and you have many of these people and
they're all up there because they govern
they're going to rule for you
and maybe they take all these irrational
decisions
and so yeah
i think
plato's notion there was more or less
correct and
it never happened you know we never had
democracy um it's always been rule of
the rich of the rich and powerful they
rule whether for good or for bad
will they rule any better than the
masses of ignorant workers
well i don't know i i i would say that
not i i'm saying that the rich and
powerful
are a
microcosm of the workers they have
different interests but they are a
microcosm of the population
you know they're a segment of the
population
and they say well i'm going to rule
because i have the money i have the
power i'm going to do whatever i want
and so the guy rules up there and the
guy on the bottom says well i don't like
that you know i want to do this other
thing
why because he's got a different
interest or like mark said you know it's
the classes between
uh classes
they have different interests and so
yeah
it's the way the world has always run at
least
since the commercial
agricultural revolution neolithic
maybe it happened even before then the
clans were ruled by some
patriarch of some kind i'm sure it
wasn't uh equal
fully equal okay
there's always been rulers and
slaves
serfs obeyers whatever you want to call
them people at the bottom
i don't think that's ever changed well
it says here along the same lines again
um germany
tried to have their own
economy and financial system free from
foreign investment and tentacles i guess
he's referring to the hitler age you
know 1930s 40s
this stance and attempt at monetary
independence cost 14 million massacred
germans and a mental reprogramming
program that never ended
yeah you know remember a lot of this has
to do with racism
i'm sure that if hitler was rise from
the dead
today he would say well maybe it wasn't
only the jewish money that rules the
world how about the chinese money today
you know they rule a lot of the world
today maybe he he would say oh these
orientals you know and
carry uh
a war against the chinese or whatever
you know
a lot of it is racism because they want
to get the population behind them they
they know the population
is separated by races and by religions
and
aside from differences political
differences
and so
you know the politicians they take
advantage of that they steer the masses
in one direction or the other based on
you know what people believe out there
and they say oh people hate blacks okay
we're going to talk against blacks oh
people hate jews we're going to talk
about the jews and uh oh they hate the
orientals let's talk about orientals the
orientals are in the news quite a bit
lately and the arabs i mean
you know uh 50 years ago nobody talked
about the orientals or the arabs you
know they weren't powerful but now these
countries you know they started coming
up they're
becoming our equals so to speak
and so now they're in the news a little
more you know you have these air this
arab world the middle east there you
have the chinese and their influence in
the uh
uh eastern world
and yeah so uh they're in the news now
and so if we could bring some of these
people from the past like hitler
uh mussolini and so on they might have a
different opinion today about
oh it's not the jews it's it's chinese
it's just uh
politics that's what it amounts to okay
uh another file says oh no sorry this is
an article they came out
and you know we were talking about the
great reset from uh klaus schwab
and here we're talking about the great
resignation not the reset or maybe the
reset is the resignation
and what is this about well it's saying
that a lot of people are
leaving their jobs they're abandoning
their jobs or or
either they quit
or they've been furloughed or whatever
and the guy doesn't want to come back
uh they say look you know um
the amount of money you're offering me
it's not enough of an incentive to get
me back to work
okay and so these were other articles
there 4.2 million americans uh quit
their jobs
the industries where workers
quit the most listened to article
oh okay
quit the most so they have a list of
them and then another one the liberty
county workers uh
who quit
um
feel liberated
uh they lost their shackles okay
uh but the community discovers a
powerful downside and so they went into
here you have the picture okay now
hiring okay and fell says if you walk
down any sidewalk you will see now
hiring right yeah it's a lot of people
are resigning and not getting back to
their jobs
and it just gives a few examples here
restaurant hotel barber shop and
nightclub and you have all these
comments and statements from people they
interviewed them at uh these different
places in this little town and maybe you
could say it's a
like again a microcosm of what's
happening at least in the united states
and perhaps in other countries
especially in the west
and that is that people are abandoning
their jobs they're not going back
there's like 10 million jobs available
no one's taking them and so the question
is uh first of all is this uh real you
know that's one issue the other one is
if it is real
it could it be that it's because um
they're not paying you enough maybe it's
a question of money if you give me more
money i'll come back to work if you
don't uh i won't
and and some of the comments there even
from the managers you'll see it says
like
target offered 15 there in the hotel uh
group says target offered 15 an hour and
we were around 10
dollars an hour so we couldn't compete
and so on so so maybe this is just an
issue of money
should they offer more money to these
people and maybe
uh there won't be
so many jobs available
uh disposal you know
and then there's uh the socialism part
where the government says oh we have
this pandemic let's give people money uh
during the transition as a stop gap
and so they give them money and the guy
says hey you know i kind of like this i
got more time i get money
i don't think i don't want to go back to
work
i like this life you know
and unless they give me a little more
money maybe i won't go back to work and
while they're out there maybe they find
a different
activity where they can live off of
maybe they don't make as much money
maybe they don't have to pay the rent
because they move in with mom and pops
you know and uh you get all these
situations out there where
people are not going back to work
and there are jobs apparently but
low-level jobs low-paying jobs and
people are not willing to take them so
you know you figure out whether this is
going to be a problem and on top of that
you got inflation now that's happening
top of that so money is
not worthless but worth less right and
uh so
it's all coming together the question is
is whether all of this is going to lead
to a crisis
where the global economy collapses and
again when i always say that
the only economy needs to fail is the
united states economy the american
empire if that economy fails
the whole world fails you know china
can't survive europe can't survive
russia can't survive okay
and if you add to that uh maybe a world
war where they throw the nukes you know
the fireworks
well all bets are off and you better
believe that uh extinction
is uh staring us in the face
so this notion that we're gonna live
even a hundred years
uh i think is far-fetched okay
my cent's worth on that
okay uh the two coveted shots not enough
to stop omicron okay
so um
is this being pushed down your throat
shove down your throat
uh i had to get two shots to be able to
travel because they required two shots
uh i think it was uh johnson johnson has
only one shot okay great but i mean you
had to get these two shots to be fully
covered
and now they invented they discovered
they developed in the lab right a new
version the omicron
and now the two kobe chances are not
sufficient now you got to get a third
one
maybe a fourth one i mean i don't know
is this real or is this being
manipulated
you know again uh those people who talk
about conspiracy in this
context
may have a point i'm not saying that
they're right or that they're wrong
again i don't have enough information to
decide that but yeah it does
kind of make you wonder you know uh just
they're inventing all these uh variants
all these
uh
strands of covid and now you need a new
shot for this one another one for that
one another one for that one
sounds like a used car salesman trying
to sell you
something okay
uh my take on that i don't know
again i can only give you my opinion and
not any irrational explanation for that
well it says you think they can't get
away with lying about something like
kovid hiv has never been proven to cause
aids it was a big lie which the world
believed and they got away with it
don't tell me your opinion tell me your
uh your theory okay so
koben did not exist it never happened uh
what was it why were all these people in
san francisco especially
you know why were they getting
sick you know
their immune system failed
uh too much beer
you know you got to give me a theory uh
don't tell me your opinion
i appreciate your opinion but you know
you want to see the meat and the meat is
the explanation try to stick to that
also says you know narrative of super
dangerous virus yes this is a lie uh
that's an opinion
don't tell me it's your opinion
give me an explanation that's what is
strong here okay
we're doing science folks
okay uh talking about brain size the
other day here we have indeed a
smartphone is more powerful than a room
sized computer from 40 years ago sizes
in everything in neurology yeah they're
talking about brain size is brain size
everything well now you have a chip you
know that's small
can't even see it
and certainly when you look it under the
microscope i'll tell you because i've
seen millions of these right you look at
it under the microscope
1000x power
of a thousand times your eyesight
and you see all the little transistors
in there fascinating absolutely
work of art
almost as much as technology
and that little thing has more power
have more powerful than the eniac of the
1940s okay so the first computer you
know is all these tubes
a little cumbersome and they have parts
of that in uh i think it's in the
smithsonian it's in one of the museums i
think it's the smithsonian museum
and uh that was the first computer
and it could calculate you know like a
little calculator more or less that's
the power it had and today you have
these tiny
uh
integrated circuits you know chips
and they can do
billions of times the calculations that
that thing used to do so
size is not necessarily you know what
gives you brain power but you got to
consider something you know mammals that
have the bigger brains versus their
body because a whale has a bigger brain
than a human does that mean that the
whale has more intelligence than a human
no obviously we had a little different
evolution for those of you who believe
in evolution we had a different process
for coming up with how we ended up
and so the whale ended up big in in size
but its brain even though it's got a
brain
uh
which is measured with its
size
which is bigger than ours doesn't have
the ability that ours has okay
and you can go with a dolphin and
parrots and other animals which
allegedly or supposedly have
certain levels of intelligence uh above
that of an ant or a starfish right
and
you know size is not what determines
how well you you calibrate things in
there you know calculated and so on
uh and i gave the example the
neanderthals the neanderthals are said
to have had at least as big
a brain is ours
apparently they had a a little bigger
brains than our brain case bigger than
ours
uh maybe they even have bigger brains
than ours on the average uh
that make them more intelligent
uh would they be i mean they obviously
did not develop as much as we did
in our
technology and our understanding of the
universe and so on
so
it was that a sign of intelligence the
fact that they had a big brain case
and yeah in general uh if you look at
the transition over time from
assuming here right that
um uh but was it the um
the old monkeys you know the
from where we came from
um they had smaller brains
and over time they got bigger like lucy
you know for example uh they got bigger
and bigger over time and you say oh yeah
the brain expanded and that's why we
became more intelligent
that could have been the history of
humans okay but it doesn't mean that the
lion who probably had also some kind of
growth from a tiny animal to the lion
that it is today
uh also had
his brain grew but that doesn't mean
that the lion because of that can do
calculus
okay so
again think about all that brain size
does not necessarily uh translate into
more intelligence whatever intelligence
is yeah
okay and then uh phil says evolution
size of human brain is an
opposite the biggest evidence that the
so-called theory evolution is fallacy
um again don't tell me that your opinion
give me an explanation if if evolution
never happened right
fine
we'll accept that as an assumption it
never happened that theory is wrong okay
what do you propose in exchange
how did we get here uh why are all the
differences between the animals why are
some herbivores other carnivores and i
can go on and on and on
giving you all kinds of descriptions
that you would have to explain okay if
it's not evolution
what is it how did we get here was it
god and magic wand
you got to give us an explanation okay
it's not enough to say i don't believe
in it
that's not a good explanation okay just
an opinion
and it says though no direct correlation
between brain size and intelligence
that's true okay i'm saying that it's
not necessarily that way i think there
is some correlation between brain size
and intelligence at least within humans
because you know again if you take lucy
and uh
homo erectus and all our ancestors out
there
we have the biggest brain and that was
part of our
evolution for those of you who believe
in evolution
we started out a long time ago uh very
small we ended up with bigger brains
uh
was it the brain size that made us more
intelligent well
again we developed things like uh hand
eye coordination and so on and that made
us eventually develop the brain
for those of you who believe in
evolution but if you don't accept that
well you know tell me what
what explanation you provide
did just god make us out of clay and say
abracadabra and we ended up with this
brain
this big brain that we have today
proportional to our body
you know you gotta
give us an explanation okay so yeah
even though i would say that you know
brain
that intelligence is not necessarily
related to brain at the same time there
is a correlation there
and you would think that um at least
from an evolutionary perspective yeah
the brain has evolved together with the
body
uh
because you could say the same thing
about the body does
body give you more strength the fact
that you're bigger and the answer is yes
you know if you're a little ant
you don't have the strength the power
the the weight
to push your you can't push your weight
around because you got no weight
on the other hand you have you know an
elephant and you know he's got he's
mighty
and so did size make a difference well
yeah i mean i think it did you know the
whale is a big animal
and it's got this power because of its
size
and so if you say well strength is
unrelated to size
well why do we have uh boxing categories
or you know
uh weight lifting categories because
apparently weight has something to do
with size you know
and uh strength has something to do with
size
and in the same way you can say you know
that thinking the ability to think the
reasoning power has something to do with
the brain size
would a guy that's got a peanut brain
you know have the same
level of intelligence as a guy who's got
a bigger brain
i don't know i can only guess
uh certainly the connections in there
like when you have autistic people or
people with uh
brain problems of some kind
um you know they
if you look at their connections in
there the quality
it's uh different than that of a normal
human but at the same time maybe they
have the big the same size brain or even
this guy might even have a bigger brain
for all we know or a bigger brain case
you know so
size is not necessarily a determinant
but
i think it's got something to do with it
to some degree in the same way that
having strength has something to do with
size and with bigness
okay and another father puts his biases
worth there what about the brain with
most wrinkles
a wrinkled brain old brain i guess right
uh is that a closer definer of
intelligence that we can tell physically
with outsider observation
yeah i mean uh
uh yeah you can come up with all
scenarios uh the the issue you gotta
answer is uh you gotta explain okay
that's the point so
explain why
you know we have a bigger brain we than
uh proportional to our body than other
animals and we are more intelligent
and for that first you gotta start by
defining intelligence and that's already
a monster that already will occupy your
time researching believe me i did it
uh not easy to figure out what
intelligence is
or define it right uh
falsehoods uh i agree with guy mcpherson
okay
uh latest data indicates nearly 60
degrees c by 2100 fossil fuels are
subsidized to almost uh what is it
62nd per
6
whatever
per year peak oil study found that
expect that the expected peak oil
predicted by math 60 years ago of around
2000 was almost 2006 okay
was about 2006 okay civilization uh fail
for lack of maintaining complexity we
have passed peak container traffic and
complexity in the planet public
attentions
is guided to unrealistic expectations
about where we are in this
uh story
and you know what can i tell you i've
had a talk with uh guy mcpherson
and we do not see eye to eye with a good
old guy
he uh he believes that um
extinction will happen because of
climate change peak oil and all that
stuff that everybody throws around
and you know the first one that you
gotta think about is that you know the
dinosaurs never used peak oil oil of any
kind maybe to rub their backs i don't
know uh maybe
some kind of um
what is it uh
cycad oil or something
you know there was no peak oil in the
days of the dinosaurs and they
disappeared no peak oil in the days of
um
of the tri uh triassic
archosaurs and so on so peak oil is not
a common denominator that mother nature
uses to get rid of species maybe there's
something else going on how about food
you know that's what i keep saying
it's got to do something with food not
with peak oil or with climate change
what does climate change have to do with
extinction but that's what guy uh
believes he believes that
he says it's uh
you know you've got this chicken little
attitude saying oh the world's crashing
the sky is falling
and the issue there is that yeah the sky
is falling but
well there's two issues one issue he
believes
there is a solution if we just could get
our act together and do something about
it the politicians
and that's what everybody out there who
talks about climate change peak oil and
all these other
asteroids and whatever that's what they
all believe that we can do something
about extinction i think i'm the only
person on planet earth says we can't do
anything at all about extinction
extinction is a done deal
we have no way of fighting or doing
anything about extinction you heard it
here okay
so when people say well what's the
solution bill there is no solution and
that's where we disagree with with guy
that's one of the issues the other one
is that you know he believes it's got to
do with climate change and maybe peak
oil in some of the things that you hear
about in the news today he thinks that's
going to cause some kind of catastrophe
and i'm saying we won't even make it to
the 21st century to the 2100s right to
the end of the century
there's no way
we're going to go way before then in my
opinion because
you know right now we are headed towards
zero population growth sometime around
mid-century if things continue as they
are now i don't think we
i don't think i think it's going to
happen before then
but if we continue as we are now we're
going to hit uh zero population growth
mid centuries or thereabouts and that
means the economy
by then it's not going to grow
okay because in the ultimately
the economy of the world economy grows
because there's demand and demand is
population no population no growth no
demand etc etc
and so at that point you hit a brick
wall you have this bottleneck a lot of
companies expect more sales next year
they won't get them they fire people
because they fire people they have less
purchases
less demand
and it's just a cycle and i think that
happened very fast
uh just like in
if you look at the 19th century we grew
exponentially in the same way we go down
exponentially
okay so
yeah that's that's the way i look at
things
and so and i don't think there's
anything that anyone can do
anything about that no politician no
economist can do anything about that
okay uh
you have to kill the bank industry
uh again conspiracy right the financial
industry that's it once done a new era
will be
uh will raise
people actually believe that
uh
there's gonna be a reset of some kind
and that once that reset is done
finally we're gonna live
in a paradise you know things are going
to be okay we could just get those
bankers off our pack you know
uh it says bill uh proposal is to be
extinct exactly and however i like to be
with hope
well maybe you have a false sense of
security you know maybe uh
maybe you have too much hope and there
is no hope maybe you're just uh fooling
yourself i mean you know if if
if you want to feel good
and you say well i'm not gonna listen to
you anymore bill i'm gonna go to this
other channel and it gives me hope yeah
fine you know go there and listen to
beautiful music in your eyes they say
you're gonna live forever and uh
and you know we're gonna get to this era
where we have the
technological singularity and we're all
going to
have the robots fix our body so that
maybe we live forever and we won't have
the bankers on top of it we won't have
to work we'll have the robots doing
everything for us yeah you can hear all
this beautiful stuff from hollywood
and then you come here and here we say
put your feet back on the ground and
we're going to tell you what's going to
happen what's going to happen is very
soon there's going to be a collapse of
the global economy when not if but when
that happens
food will be no more because no one will
have an incentive to produce or
distribute food to the cities you've got
billions of people die in a matter of
weeks
so yeah it's not a question of hope it's
not that i'm pessimistic
it's a question that i try to be as
realistic as possible
if you uh do not subscribe to that
theory you have a different theory well
i'd like to hear it of course
again uh don't tell me your opinion tell
me your theory
okay here we have another foul says uh
what happens when we die
i'm assuming he's referring to
extinction to humans not
individually when we die we die that's
it but when humans die you know when we
become extinct well you know we're out
of the way
and we were a big influence on this
planet uh
you could say we modified it or
destroyed it uh
quite uniformly all around you know we
created our world and when we die you
know there's a couple uh videos out
there that show what happens when humans
are no longer here and you see the grass
is growing over time right grass is
growing underneath the cement in the
highways and so on every time becomes
you know a little different than what
you see today so if you were to come in
a million years well you would see a
different planet and one of the things
that could very likely happen is a
runaway greenhouse
uh maybe the earth turns into something
like venus
and mother nature finally got all her
you know the bugs of her skin
and when she becomes a normal
planet like all the others out there you
know just a rock
with a barren surface like the moon
i think that's what's going to happen in
the long run you know we're not
important and will anyone ever find us
absolutely not
you know we'll be crushed at some point
maybe the sun expands in a million years
or yeah sorry in a few million years uh
more likely like in a billion years and
uh
i think the number is 100 million and
and
within that time no one's going to come
and visit the solar system and again i'm
saying that no one can travel no life
can travel interstellarly
it's forbidden by father universe okay
no one can travel interstellarly it's
irrational to think of that okay but
that's the
bologna they sell you i mean i don't
mind
if it's science fiction i love to watch
it just like anyone else the problem is
when you believe it and you believe that
the martians came here the klingons came
here the et's are about to arrive or we
can communicate with them that's the
fantasy
now we cannot travel interstellar is
forbidden by father universe and i've
talked about that in the past but the
point here is that you know um because
of that no one's going to come here this
notion of panspermia that people have
that a bug crawled on a rock and the
meteor you know came all the way to
our
side of the universe our neighborhood
and populated the earth from that bug
absolute nonsense absolute nonsense no
such thing as panspermia in mother and
father universe's
universe world
okay
um
we had a
miss universe contest and
here you see the evolution we had the
11th century miss universe and was run
by the arabs i think okay that's where
it started
then we went to about the 16th century
that changed all the women you know
uh they
showed their stuff but they had to show
that they
had some um
you know some skills
and so they had to bake bread and who
knows what in those days you know maybe
work uh the furnaces
uh 20th century they came up with the
bikinis and
uh you can see there the girls are
showing their
uh their bodies in bikinis and now we
have the 21st century version and
they're removing the bikini segment no
more bikinis
uh so
my opinion is you know that the golden
age
was the 20th century now i'm not an
expert but that's what i
vouch for you know
uh but there's been a change now there's
uh there's been in a uh
a change in the
this year's or not only this year's but
in the last few years
and now we have um
for example in this miss universe
contest we had
the
representative from nevada
and it's uh
this person is a mispronoun
i mean i meant to say uh mispronounced
they mispronounced his name because his
name was tommy
and they uh mispronounced it as sally
and
yeah right now we have these x and y's
competing against the double x's
which is kind of weird you know i'm
saying hey you know i've been to nevada
i've been to the casinos
uh several times
and i've seen some beautiful women out
there in nevada and especially you know
in that ambient you know casinos and so
on and i'm saying
this guy is the most beautiful
guy in all of nevada that's the best he
could find
and yeah we have all these uh crossovers
you know competitions here we have
another one uh let's follow uh again
mispronounced
uh he's uh
his name is johnny and i think they call
him betty or something like that
and he works for victoria's secret this
is what they want to show you
okay and so the question is um
whether this is something normal okay
would is this the future
okay uh for the new generations
uh here you see them again all these
folks and you have also the crossover in
uh i showed this a couple weeks ago
where you have the um fellows who are
changing their sex and doing some
kickboxing and
all that good stuff you know they're
fighting against women
and so the question is is this normal is
does this have a future is this the
future of the world that we're seeing
here
uh or do we want to go back to
civilizations to the 20th century
so
food for thought you know i mean is
it and again one of the comments made
for the miss universe contest was that
you know it's changed quite a bit and a
lot of people have lost interest
and i don't blame them i mean uh if
they're gonna remove the bikini segment
you know here they here they're removing
the bikini segment from there they want
the girls dress because they're
competing for college uh
careers or who knows what and here you
have the other ones in ocean city and
they want to show their breasts
topless you know so the world's upside
down today you know so the question is
does that have a future or
are we moving in in a
certain direction
uh
that also is a sign
that
something is wrong
and that maybe um
you know just maybe it's part of that
extinction process where some things are
going to be
weird
food for thought
okay um
so let's get on with the
segment on um
physics
and what are we going to do today we're
going to talk a little bit about
electricity but we had a couple
questions a couple of things that
remained
apparently unresolved for some people so
let's get to those first okay
let's look at this one file says
him up here says chris langdon he talked
about that the other day where i
mentioned him and basically said the
universe is god and we're equivalent to
its brain cells okay i don't know why he
says it's
uh should say his but
yeah we're in the age of pronouns
um a lot of the ctmu okay uh israel
meaning the theory that this langan fell
proposed is restating old esoteric
beliefs using math and predicate logic
it's not physics it's
metaphysics it is worth reading
in my opinion well i don't think so and
let me tell you why and i'll go over
here with the only good thing that mr
rutherford said and that was a long time
ago okay being in a century he said all
science is either physics or stamp
collected
you know you have all these so-called
philosophers plato and kant and
ayn rand and so on and all these people
call themselves or thought of themselves
as philosophers and no there's no such
thing as as
you know none of these
things
like ontology and metaphysics and
epistemology and philosophy of physics
no such monsters there's either physics
or there's stem collecting okay so
that's one thing that mr rutherford said
correctly okay
and so you know uh this nonsense about
metaphysics what the hell is metaphysics
you know uh you either do physics or you
do stamp collecting period okay
straightforward
okay and here we do physics so
if you're going to move concepts around
well you're doing stamp collecting
because you haven't provided a physical
interpretation and explanation for a
mechanism
okay another fellow says another issue
needs to be resolved in this issue mass
work versus weight some people are still
stuck on this and they're going to fight
it
to the last breath because this is what
they learned in high school or college
or whatever and we need to settle this
and kill the notions because it's
irrational okay and we'll see it here
fella says weight is a dynamic concept
it takes two frames of reference to
measure
your scale at zero and your scale with
weight
and again uh no weight is not dynamic
weight is
uh static
and let me show you here let me give you
a
picture
of why it's a static concept okay
and here's it's a static concept why
because uh science doesn't do
measurement okay that's the religion of
mathematics okay in science we have to
explain we have to give a rational
explanation to a mechanism to a physical
interpretation that's what science and
physics are about can you either do
physics or stamp collecting again
and
it's in mathematics the mathematical
physicists those are the people who talk
about measurement and about equations
and about describing we talk about
explaining that's the difference okay
and weight is location specific you have
a different weight for
different
locations
in the universe even before you measure
you have weight
even when you're falling you know
through the from the sky uh you say well
i don't feel my weight yeah you don't
feel your weight but hopefully you did
not acquire weight all of a sudden when
you hit the scale
and then it turns out that the
mathematicians
not me but them they're telling you that
once it hits the scale
that's called mass
because
that weight that pull of gravity against
of the ball in this case against the
scale now it's static it's staying there
it doesn't go any further
and uh the needle moved right
now
now you have what they call mass it's a
measure of the amount of matter that you
are
measuring
and one fellow says out there says well
we can convert it you know by using the
uh the
mole equation you know we can we can
convert those uh into atom we know
approximately how many atoms there are
in there
fine if that's what
mass is uh specify your answer
in quantity of atoms tell me there is a
trillion and one atoms that would be the
way to specify mass
but to say it's one kilogram that's a
measurement i thought that was weight
and again we don't have to
put the weight or throw it on something
you already weigh
you already have also a certain mass
number of atoms
be before we measure anything before we
put you on the scale the skill is only
to find out exactly how many
uh either atoms or how much you weigh
okay that's what the scale is for
before you put anything on the scale you
already have both weight and you have
mass
you have a certain number of ma atoms in
your body that's called mass okay number
number of atoms and you have a certain
weight which is how much the earth or
the moon or the sun is pulling on you
on the astronaut okay so you already
have a certain weight a certain mass
before
you do anything before you get a number
and people don't understand that they
think that uh you gotta run an
experiment weigh something on a scale
you know put it on a scale and then you
only have weight but that you don't have
weight until you do that not true
okay so try to please get that through
your head okay
and again i don't know why people have
difficulty uh understanding that maybe
their religion is being
sacrificed and they don't like that
that's what they learned in by rote
and so when someone tells them look you
you just memorize stuff for the test on
friday
and you get the test right but you never
learned anything because you never
learned what was secretly happening in
that invisible
world of yours
you know and now you say well no you
already had weight you already had mass
before you put it on the scale and said
whoa
i thought you needed to measure i
thought you needed to weigh something
you don't you have weight before you
weigh it
you have mass before you mass it
okay so let's get on with electricity
now here we go and
we start out by defining we have to find
out what a definition of electricity is
out there
and the first rule is that if you can
define it
that word is not an object does not
represent an object
objects we do not define objects we
point to name we draw we present them we
show them you know
uh
object as that which has shape not that
which you you know you can see or touch
okay and uh so if electricity is defined
electricity is not an object
i had people from the electric universe
who told me what do you mean electricity
is not an object of course it's an
object it's a thing
okay uh why says well stick your fingers
in an outline you'll find out why
that was their answer yeah you get a
shock and so the question was that
electricity or was it an atom was it an
electron
you know electricity is a concept
dynamic concept to be more precise
whereas what touched you must have been
an atom or a part of an atom
and so an atom is not electricity
electricity is not an atom electricity
is a process okay and all dynamic
processes are concepts so how do they
define it they say
electricity motion of matter that has a
property of electric charge
okay i love the fact that they use the
word electric to define electricity okay
that's great
uh
and uh but let's find out what this
chargey thing is says chargey it's the
uh
the physical property of matter that
causes it to experience a force when
placed in wet in an electric
field
so we have the electric there
electromagnetic right electric field
and so electricity is a charge and
charges electric great
uh sounds like a circular
definition you know
go around in circles here uh so what is
a field well the field is
a bunch of numbers
that's what it is
a value at each point in space
so uh we have a bunch of numbers and
what they're saying is what that you
experience if you're put in an electric
field
or electromagnetic field right you
experience a force well we call that a
charge
and so you have this lady here we put
her in a uh
field bunch of numbers floating around i
guess
and she experiences a force
and they say that that was charge
okay uh but what is it that
touched you
was it this
chargey thingy what is it a ghost a
spirit
i mean we need to get to the bottom of
this uh charge thing
apparently because that's what's going
to define electricity we need to figure
out what electricity is they say it's
something related to charge charge is
some kind of spirit
that
you know causes a force on you when
you're in a
field of some kind not a poppy field not
a marijuana field no it's got to be an
electric field okay or electromagnetic
okay let's find out
turns out that this
chargey thing
also moves
okay even though it's defined so we have
a concept here that's going to be moving
around it says charge originates from
the electron and proton okay that's in
the atom right so now we know where it
comes from by convention the charge
carried
okay so we're gonna carry this charge
you know remember you can carry
watermelons you can carry uh chairs
maybe even rocks they're gonna carry a
charge okay carried by electrons is
deemed negative
and that by a protons positive okay so
we have uh
these negative and positive charges that
are carried by electrons okay and
protons right okay let's find out where
they're getting to this uh each electron
carries the same charge of approximately
minus uh 1.6 times 10 to the minus 19
coulombs
okay it sounds like a number so this
charge thing apparently is some kind of
number
and so how do you carry a number
you know so now it's getting weird
because they define charge as what a
force that you experience in an electric
field
now they're going to say it's positive
and negative it comes from
the atom apparently and then you have
the electron the proton they carry these
1.6 times 10 to the minus 19 units known
as coulombs
so i'm not sure what they're talking
about i think they're confusing numbers
with physical entities here
it says the movement of electric charge
you're going to move this number is
known as an electric current so now we
know what an electric current is which
is this electricity thingy and it's the
movement of this charge which is a
number so we're going to be moving this
1.6 coulombs concept right and that
movement of that coulomb is what they
call
electric current or electricity
i hope you're following through okay
uh current can consist of any moving
charge particles now they're talking
about moving particles okay so are we
moving particles are we moving numbers
what is it that we're moving
well the way they do that they have this
device that measures
measures right remember measuring
and uh what does it measure it measures
numbers it measures
units measures quantities
so they're not measuring particle
they're not really measuring a thing
what they're concerned about is the
number they get out of that device and
they say oh so many particles each
particle has so many so many coulombs
we're not interested in the particles
we're not interested in what's going on
in there because we don't even know if
there you are particles what we're
interested is how many coulombs have
gone by
that's what they're looking at okay
and it says uh
charge in motion again constitutes a
current okay electric current will not
flow through an electric uh electrical
insulator they don't explain to you why
it doesn't flow they just say it won't
flow but then we're talking about
electric current flowing what was
electric current what was the movement
of a charge which is a number so we have
the flow of a movement
oh that's great i mean i think we're
learning quite a bit here the flow of a
movement and what's the movement of the
movement of a number coulombs
okay i hope you learned a lot
okay from all this uh
these definitions that these people have
okay
let's see if we can uh find out what
they're looking at okay what is this
movement of charges okay so here you
have says when a charge is placed in a
location okay with a non-zero electric
field a charge a force will act on it
okay so we have this force what is the
force
uh
concept because we're not talking about
a rock we're talking about a force
and force is what pull or push i guess
so i guess there's pull or push
is gonna push
or pull
okay so the push and pull
is gonna
be uh affecting this uh this charge okay
if the charge moves okay
this number this 1.6 coulomb 10 to the
minus 19 coulombs if the charge moves
the electric field would be doing work
we talked about work the other day okay
on the electric charge the presence of a
charge gives rise to an electrostatic
force charges exert a force on each
other
so you have
very well mixture because
they say charge is essentially this 1.6
times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs okay
that's what charge is
because they're talking about the charge
on the electron they say the electron
carries the charge you know like the
watermelon or the rock that you carry on
your shoulder so you're carrying this
charge
whatever that means physically from a
physical standpoint
and this causes a force causes work if
it's
moving in an electric field
okay let's see if we can go a little
deeper on this see if we can get to the
bottom of this here we have the field
what is it you look it up it says a
value for each point in space and time
okay so let's illustrate this we're just
going to go by what they say okay we're
just going to go literally
take them at face value they say a value
for each point in space and time let's
do it okay we can do this i'm sure we
can here it is okay there's your field
value at each point in space and time
okay
so we have the field okay now what do we
got to do next well we got to put a
charge in there and for that you need to
know what a charge is okay so what is
the charge okay let's put it in there
there it is charge is 1.6 times 10 to
the minus 19 coulombs
and what are they going to do well this
is the charge moves inside the field and
that's going to cause work and force and
all this other good stuff one charge
affects another
okay and that looks uh more or less like
this okay now that we have it there
there's your charge moving okay
we have numbers moving inside numbers
that's all we have so far according to
their definitions
according to you know we're following
them to the to the letter
and you might say bill you're making fun
of these guys you're you're uh
all these people did all so much work
for the last hundred years uh 150 years
maybe
uh on trying to figure all this out
you're just making fun of them
well no i'm i'm applying what they're
saying
i'm using their words their own words
i'm not raising any you know straw men
here i'm using their own words i'm
saying what are you talking about
i'm talking about a number what's a
what's a charge it's a coulomb of some
kind what point say
that's a number
okay what is a field a bunch of numbers
so we have a number floating in a bunch
of numbers maybe they're moving maybe
they're not moving you know but the
point is
we have numbers inside of numbers what
does this have to do with physics
what have we learned about what's going
on in that invisible world
you know
a number moving inside a bunch of
numbers
field of numbers uh
what uh value of each point in space
so this is what we have this is i'm just
going strictly by what these people are
saying okay i'm not putting words in
their mouth i'm not
making fun of them even though
that's how it comes across
okay
okay
so let's find out we get a little deeper
in all this electricity stuff says a
lightweight ball suspended from a string
can be charged okay we're going to
charge it because we're going to put all
these coulombs in there right by
touching it with a glass rod that has
itself been charged by rubbing with a
cloth okay good if a similar ball is
charged by the same glass rod it is
found to repel the first why because
they both have the same charge either
they are both so-called negative or they
are both positive we still don't
understand what negative and positive
are they seem to be just
uh descriptions
maybe qualitative descriptions because
we have no idea what that means
physically
okay and
so if they have the same charge they
push each other apart two balls that are
charged with a rubber uh rubbed amber
rod also repel each other okay however
if one ball is charged by the glass rod
and the other by an amber rod the two
balls are found to attract each other
and again all we have is just a
description
and you say bill why uh why did you put
the magic wand
well you know that's the rod that i used
but the point here is that so far we
have magic because they have not
explained how this is done all they said
is it it is so we saw it in the lab
well yeah you saw it in the lab but i
mean what are we talking about here why
does this happen what is causing
uh the positive to attract the pause to
repel the positive negative negative and
for the positive to attract the negative
and vice versa
what is happening there why are they
doing that what is this negative what is
this positive why what's happening in
that invisible world
and all they do is they have a
description and say it does so at this
speed or at this acceleration this is
the force and
this is how much work it created and
those are just numbers those are units
numbers followed by units what have we
learned about what's going on inside
there what have we learned about
physics
and again uh mr rutherford says you
either do physics or you do stamp
collecting
this is stem collecting this is just
measuring and saying this is what i saw
in the lab
well you don't need to use brains for
that
i mean you just have to say okay i went
to the uh
to the
lab what did you see well here i saw a
ball and i let go right in
it fell
downwards
so you described and say it went
so fast
downwards it was such a distance in so
much time
that science
that you described why the ball or how
the ball fell to the
floor
why don't you explain why the ball
didn't go up to the ceiling that's what
we would like to understand why did it
go downwards what caused it to go
downwards that's what that's where you
have to use your brains but to say that
you observed and you measured that the
ball fell downwards every time and you
can do it also at home you can
repeatable experiment yeah so
what have we learned about physics oh we
didn't have a mathematical description
so far okay so this is where we're
getting with this electricity thingy
here okay and um so
uh says you know we're gonna look at
this positive negative okay
and so we need to find out what we mean
by this right a positive current is
defined as what having the same
direction a flow from the most positive
part of the circuit to the most negative
part like if we understood something
there you know a positive current is
what uh from the positive to the n to
the negative
great current defined in this manner is
called conventional current okay but the
motion of negatively charged electrons
around an electric circuit is deemed
positive in the opposite direction to
that of the electrons however depending
on the condition uh conditions an
electric current can consist of a flow
of charged particles okay we're gonna
now it's not flow of charges but charged
particles
what are those particles they are
coulombs that's what those particles are
in either direction or even in both
directions at once
so have we learned anything so it means
the charges can move in one direction
they can move in both directions
and
they call it the
if it goes in this direction we call it
positive it goes in that derivative and
call it negative
those are all descriptions so far we
have not learned why what causes
something to go in the negative
direction or in the positive direction
we have no idea what why one charge also
opposes a similar charge and attracts a
dissimilar charge why a negative
attracts a positive and why they flowing
and then when you get down to it they
say well what was this charge that you
talked about for the last two hours oh
it's a number
1.6 times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs
that's what it was
okay so uh this takes us to alternate
current you know there's a difference
here
uh remember you got direct current which
is the flow of electron beads i guess
from atom to atom from one
pole to another from the positive to the
negative maybe it's the other way around
who knows anymore
uh but then you have the alternate
current and that's a big problem because
you're saying hold it if
you turn on the circuit you you have a
closed circuit and now all the electrons
flow in one direction right and that
causes some effect
because you can put a light bulb there
and it turns it on great but now you're
gonna run it in one direction then run
it in the opposite direction immediately
so it goes back and forth
at great speeds
are the electrons going all around to
the other side and then coming all the
way back to the other side is that
what's happening
they're going around in complete circle
in one way very fast and then in the
other direction very fast
and they say no not quite only when
direct current does the do the electrons
move in one direction but when you have
alternate current it goes back and forth
and here it is direct current is
unidirectional flow from the positive
part of a circuit to the negative okay
great this flow is carried by electrons
i like the fact that they carry the
flows yeah yeah they carry motion all
the time like the way they talk
alternating current pulses
back and forth within a conductor
without the charge moving any net
distance over time so now for
alternating current there is very little
motion it just goes like back and forth
or up and down there's no real motion
going to one end and the other
so how do they produce
effects if no electron is
reaching you know the opposite pole you
know like if an electron is negative
so-called negative and it has to reach
the positive pole great
i mean if if it just moves back and
forth locally it's not reaching the end
of the line it's not going to the end of
the station
so
so how do we
imagine this
in the real world in the real world of
physics
it says it delivers energy
now we introduce the word energy
first in one direction and then in
reverse okay while the particles
themselves can move quite slowly
sometimes with an average drift velocity
only fractions of a millimeter per
second
the electric field that drives them
itself propagates at close to the speed
of light enabling electrical signals to
pass rapidly along the wires
so what they're saying here is uh
the electrons they're not going all the
way they're just moving back and forth
locally we don't know why
we don't know what are they changing
atoms are they moving from one atom to
the other or what's going on here okay
and and they say well that's moving very
slowly they drift very slowly they
usually use this explanation for
alternating current okay
and what they say is that the what what
really travels is the field
okay
and uh the signals so what's what's
really moving are the field and the
signals and here you get an idea okay
you have this situation here's the
direct current okay let me get this out
of here
and uh here you have the
uh
direct current that goes in one
direction they go all the way and this
is what they'll show you for uh direct
current
okay uh no problem i think uh we can
deal with it
but what happens when you look at uh
alternating current and here you see it
side by side
so now uh
is that a little weird in one case the
electrons go all the way and we can
understand all the electrons going
through there
but in the other the electrons just go
back and forth or maybe it's up and down
maybe they just
vibrate up and down the question is are
the electrons
going from one atom to the next that's
the question
and
if they are are they coming back
to the first atom so the so an electron
leaves one atom goes to the one the
neighboring atom now it's coming back
and coming to the first atom back again
or maybe to another one another neighbor
nearby but it's going back and forth and
the question is what is triggering
uh this electron bead
to move
you know from in this uh
conduction band in other words going
from one atom to the next and back again
what's the mechanism
to say it is so
is just their interpretation it doesn't
mean that they've figured out how the
universe works how mother nature does
this magic trick
okay so
unless they can illustrate it you know
uh
they've said nothing nothing in physics
they did stamp collecting
and that's what they did
okay here we have a file we talked about
the other day his name is derek miller
and he uh says that
you know the electrons really don't flow
like all around what they do is they
move very slowly just a
millimeter or micrometer or who knows
how little they move
and again you would think that they're
moving from atom to atom and they don't
talk about that very well what's
happening there because they say yeah
the electrons move
what's happening i mean are you saying
that and the electrons moving from atom
they add them to add them to atom to add
them all the way to the
end of the station the end of the
circuit
and
then when you have alternating transit
moves from one atom to the second atom
then back to the first atom again
how does that make the light
turn on
i mean and how is that what's triggering
what's pushing the electron
out of the atom and forcing it to be at
the
neighboring atom and back again what
what force what is this force what is it
a spirit or what is it okay and here we
have mr derek muller and he said well
you know electrons don't really go
around
okay uh they do but they don't and he's
got really a confusing
uh
image of all this dynamic image where it
shows the electrons moving in one
direction remember from atom the atom
right
but the current is flowing in the
opposite direction see i see it here
okay you have the
electrons which are those green balls
they're moving towards the left but he
says the current is towards the right
great i mean you know very very
straightforward okay we don't know what
he's talking about what's moving to the
right if all the electrons are moving to
the left okay but um
so so that's how he illustrates it but
then he says this notion is wrong
anyways okay and what it truly is is
something like this okay he didn't
illustrate it i had to illustrate it for
him what he said and he's saying it's
more or less something like this okay
where the uh the electrons are really
like moving very little maybe moving to
the side maybe back again especially an
alternating current or maybe they're
just moving up and down
uh you know from atom to adam or who
knows because they don't specify what is
happening physically they just say we we
measure the coulombs we measure the
electric current uh the ac the dc the
current uh the amps you know they're
talking about measurement they're not
talking about what's physically
occurring in that
region
uh of the wire okay along the wire
and okay let me get move this out of
here give me a second here
okay uh so what's the problem with this
well among others uh this is the big
problem the problem is they don't have
an atom we don't know what their atom
looks like okay
and here is this is their atom make it a
little bigger here
what they're saying is the electrons are
moving from atom to atom but this
model
requires
the planetary model or
the bore and rutherford planetary model
of the atom it's saying that you know
you have this little bead that's going
around
or is in different energy levels
uh within certain orbitals as they're
known
okay great so what keeps that electron
from flying away completely why does it
stay there and why what causes it to
move from atom to atom later on
so we don't have causes we don't have
mechanisms all we have is an assumption
that the electron is a little bead
little particle that is in an orbital or
energy level
which is a region around an atom
for we know
for no reason why it's doing that we
don't know why that electron doesn't
fall to the nucleus we don't know why
that electron doesn't fly spontaneously
away
and then when you have electricity like
you see up there direct current okay
it goes from atom to atom for no reason
whatsoever simply because it likes it
say it's a voltage well what's a voltage
well think of it as a river flowing like
you know
downhill from the mountain to the valley
that's an analogy give me what's
happening inside that world
they cannot imagine they cannot
make sense of it
that's the problem so electricity is
first defined
which is a problem
because people want to treat it as a
physical object and if you define it
it's not an object an object is that
which you can
which has shape which you can point to
and draw and illustrate and see okay but
you can see it only
because it has shape even if you're not
around it has shape
irrespective of you and you don't have
to touch it either you know
an object is that which i shape does
electricity have shape
and no because it's a process it's a
it's like fire fire is combustion there
is no thing called fire but people say
but i can point to that i see something
i see a shape yeah
it's a process it's known as combustion
the object is uh oxygen
molecule or atom
okay so
we have to learn the wording in physics
okay so
what do we have here um
here we have the electric universe and
they
uh they fight against the establishment
but they they do the same thing as
quantum mechanics
uh
i mean their name is electric universe
and here you look them up under the
thunderbolts project which is their
site right their primary site
and you say what is that electricity
okay and they say electricity is a
fundamental what quality of matter
so it is used to characterize other
things thus consensus opinion is lacking
precision in other words they're already
giving you the fine print they're saying
they're not going to be able to define
it like all bedrock presumptions such as
gravity or time reducing electric
terminology into smaller units is
impossible because it lies
at the bottom of the lexical well
and you can see the troubles these
people have in defining the word
electricity even though it forms part of
the title of their organization the
electric universe electricity how do
they define it they define it as the
flow
it's a flow of something okay
electricity is a flow therefore
electricity is not a physical object
because it is a flow
give me a second here
and um
uh so what is it flow of what electric
charge it travels it says this flow
travels okay it travels through a
circuit okay
and
then you see next to it there it says
electricity moves through a dc circuit
in the wires as particles of charge so
we have electricity is defined as a flow
now they're going to say that
electricity this
it moves okay so the flow is moving
okay
and so we we uh we run into all these
troubles okay
because they
you know they have all this wording that
uh simply takes them uh
in uh in all these directions that they
cannot explain they cannot justify they
cannot illustrate for you they define
electricity as the flow and then they
say the flow is moving
and then they say that electricity is a
physical object okay so you figure it
out
okay so um
here we have uh their version they say
uh what is electricity it's the flow of
electron beads from atom the atom here
you have a circuit you know anode and
cathode and this is essentially what
they have in mind
what do we propose instead well we
propose something that looks like this
okay
compared to theirs okay let me get this
one out of there
and what you see is a comparison we're
saying that uh all these shells electron
shells are merged
and they spin in situ so they're
twirling around so our version of
electricity is a little different than
theirs
and again yes electricity is a process a
dynamic process
okay so let's get to the conclusions
okay
what have we learned about electricity
from all these people well here it is
uh math is electricity is the flow of
charges
that's what they say what is a charge
well it's a number
what is a field it's a number a bunch of
numbers
so we have one a charge number floating
inside a field which is a bunch of
numbers okay that's that's what you have
today because that's how those words are
defined it's not that i'm
uh
you know raising a straw men or putting
words in their mouth this is how these
words are defined if you don't like them
define them in a different way if you
think they are physical objects
illustrate them that's how simple it is
and if charge is a number and field is a
bunch of numbers well you have a number
and a bunch of numbers
that's what uh
forces or power uh the work that uh
charge
does inside a field
you know what have we learned
and so charge uh moving in a field
that's what a force is okay
it performs work we talked about that
the other day
uh there's no definition for positive or
negative okay we don't have any uh
notion of what that means in physics
you know they just say positive
arbitrarily we're going to call this one
here positive this one here negative
that's it
whatever that means you know what what
does that mean in physical terms we have
no idea
and why does positive attract negative
again we have no idea we have a
mathematical description no physical
explanation
ac circuits don't flow they drift
locally let's just go back and forth see
when when you see that going around
that's a direct current and they say see
this is electricity all these beads
going around from atom to atom but then
for uh ac
they have them going back and forth
between the atoms and you say well so
this electron never reached the terminal
you see what i'm saying it just goes
back and forth in fact it drifts slowly
they say in both directions i guess
so the ac is a little different than dc
uh in in the notion that they have the
physical interpretation of what's
happening to the electron that's my
point okay
fields and signals are the ones that
flow and they flow at the speed of light
okay so what they say no the electron is
not what's flowing what's flowing is the
field
what is the field bunch of numbers what
is a signal a concept
information
they say information flows energy flows
those are all concepts so we haven't
learned anything we don't know what
physical entity is flowing you know you
can say that uh river flows why because
there are atoms so the atom is floating
and flowing
we can understand that but when you have
a number that's flowing well that's a
little
difficult to illustrate okay
and then yeah they use the planetary
model of the atom that's another no-no
uh rope model very simple it's a merged
shells uh twirling in situ and it looks
more or less like this
okay
that's our model it's all physical
it's all done with objects okay we have
uh the atoms are merged
the electron shells okay
or membranes they're merged and they
swing the
threads around themselves which are
going to form the magnetic
field
field is not a bunch of numbers at least
a magnetic field is not it's a bunch of
threads physical threads that are
twerting around the atoms aligned atoms
because that's what electricity is
okay let's get on with the uh
with the uh what is it the questions and
comments that people made
this week
and here we have uh first one
let me uh get myself set up here get rid
of this one
okay
uh
i went all the way to the other side
fella says
um says why the quantum wave function
collapses okay he's trying to answer
this the wave function completely
explains and simplifies quantum
mechanics down to such simplicity a
grade school student can understand it
uh yeah uh maybe
people understand it when they think
they understand it but
they're not understanding physics what
they're understanding is mathematics
the explanation is what's irrational you
can't say a wave function has anything
to do with physics there's no such
physical entity known as a wave function
especially if a wave function collapse
okay
and the other file says the wave
function is a mathematical tool it
doesn't really describe a single
particle but a whole set of identically
prepared
particles
so it's a bunch of particles okay great
and i put particle in quotation for two
reasons oh i don't see any one let's see
why the first reason is that something
is only a particle when it is a
has a detectable interaction with
something on a precise location
touch
see touch
yeah they think that a thing is that
which you can touch because that's what
they do in the lab and that's what they
measure
none of that has anything to do with
particle with with why not what the
definition of the word object object is
that which has shape not that which you
can touch but see they say that the
particle becomes a particle when you
touch it until then what is it well it's
a wave function what is a wave function
a number
and so these people are all irrational
and this
person says it's so simple even a high
school student can understand it yeah
the problem is that you didn't
understand what you understood
that's the problem okay and secondly
because
uh also combination of particles can
have a
wave function in other words he's
talking about many waves the ether
that's waving around you know
in
in the ether in space because space is
made out of ether so we don't know what
it's moving in
uh nothing there is no such thing as
nothing in mathematical physics so we
don't know what they said
from a physical point of view physics we
have no idea what these people are
talking about
and another fellow says the wave
function really the excitation of the
boson and or fermion field so we have
the excitation of a field what was a
field bunch of numbers so we're going to
shake all these numbers and it's excite
them and
and that's going to be the wave function
okay so
what is a field bunch of numbers that
are shaking okay so keep that in mind
there is no physical entity called field
because it's defined by the
mathematicians as a bunch of numbers you
don't like the definition change the
definition if you think a field is an
object point to it you know make a
drawing uh illustrate it then we'll know
what you're talking about otherwise if
you're going to define it and you're
going to define it as a bunch of numbers
and then you tell me that you're going
to excite these numbers well we have a
problem with that because you're an
irrational individual
okay it stops being fuzzy or spread out
when it finally interacts with another
wave function so we have wave functions
interacting with wave functions and they
call that the quantum field theory great
we learned a lot
so we have all these concepts these
numbers that are interacting with each
other that's all we see in front of us
and you might say well bill you're
you're taking this too literally okay
make it
make it literal or or you know make it
unliterate whatever you need to do but
we need to know what's happening there
illustrate it okay don't don't talk just
illustrate
and the interaction can happen at a
collapse again you know you can go on
without and they what words do they use
both energy bosons and matter fermions
you know they have all these concepts
and they they're playing around with
concepts and they think they're being
rational
and the worst part they put this out
there like you know uh yeah we've proven
this you know this is a
this is done a done deal you just got to
memorize it from now on because it's
already been proven
and you wonder about their mental state
if they even realize what's coming out
of their mouths
and talking about that one guy says i
misrepresented him beat me up he says
do you crop do you crop and misrepresent
my comments on purpose or do you have a
reading deficiency
okay oh i'm so sorry what did i do here
okay one more time since you take any
opportunity available to mischaracterize
my arguments okay i'm so sorry i
shouldn't have done all that okay
i use object and shape as synonyms
yeah they're not synonyms that's why i
have to clarify that's why i have to
beat you up you know
let me get my
toe roller
i'm going to do some justice here okay
um
what he says it's
what has one boundary
so he defines object
or uh and or you know uh shape right as
that which has one boundary
and he says anything unbounded is not an
object is it a shape
okay
yeah
okay and then he goes on he says the
following or this is uh how i
um you know this is where i have to use
my dough roller
that which has single boundary that's
what shape is okay what is boundary well
he says it's left undefined
well why why leave it undefined i think
he should define every word in the
dictionary i mean if we're going to
define let's let's be serious about it
let's define every single world in the
dictionary or we won't understand what
shape is because we don't know what
boundary is we don't know what an object
is you know let's define every word in
the dictionary okay that's what we
should do
but he said boundaries left undefined
but can be put into everyday speech as
where the shape ends well why couldn't
we leave the word shape
in everyday speech as you know whatever
it is why did we have to define the word
shape
and again i say that only idiots
attempt to define the word shape but as
an idiot an individual with big ideas in
fact you can see it here the guy defines
shape as a single boundary and then he
defines boundary is where shape ends
well sounds a little circular doesn't it
i mean you know uh these are the bright
guys that think that they're going to be
able to define words and the reason they
do that you know all of this is because
the the definition of the word object
destroys their religion okay
so no uh
shape and object are not synonyms
one refers to the thing and the other
one is a qualifier
of the thing one is an adjective shape
is the is an adjective for the purposes
of physics not a noun on the other hand
object refers to the thing in front of
you and so the object is what you point
into what you drew what you illustrated
the thing that has shape there whereas
the
shape
is a property of that thing so one is a
qualifier one is an adjective one
describes
what the object has in common with all
other objects they're not synonyms
and how do you explain that to them you
know these people
see their religion die before their very
eyes because you're saying hey you know
the word object destroys your religion
they realize this so they they're going
to fight it with everything they've got
they say no but i'm not going to let you
kill my uh religion you're not going to
rape my virgin you know here
what are you
doing okay so they continue a lot of
things are related to object again you
know fellas says two objects may
completely superimpose without fusing
okay remember i said uh
touch the word touch
is uh blending you have to have two
objects turned into one that's the
definition of touch okay zero
distance
okay zero distance blending etc i don't
know how i can
you know in fact i'll illustrate it in a
minute but he says with this framework i
define touching as two objects whose
boundaries overlap
well how did they overlap how did they
touch
if there's space between them
otherwise you wouldn't have two objects
you still have space there and as long
as they have a boundary
they have space between them because
that the ultimate thing that
encapsulates them is this non-thingy we
call space as long as there's space
there you're going to have a boundary
only when there is no space whatsoever
when
the boundaries disappear
that's when you have touch now you can
talk about touch
what happened they blended they turned
into one object a single object in this
case a figure eight it would be with two
balls there right
okay now it's possible to do push pull
without objects permanently fusing or
having a magical gap of no contact
between
so they reach these irrational
conclusions that when they are because
they misdefined the word touch because
they have an erroneous irrational
version of what touch is they say
they don't need to touch um
my definition of touch is
boundaries overlap and now i can
continue right with this irrational
definition and say see now i know i can
pull or push
even though they're not touching
the guy is killing his own definition
okay
will you answer how your threads push
and pull without touching
my god and i keep tying on the threads
don't touch
so he says how do they push without
touching well they don't push they go
through each other that's the point
but let's go step by step here okay
here we have uh touching according to
what he's saying or what many people say
they think it's the surface against
surface but as long as you have two
objects like you see there
they're not touching because you have
space between them
and you say well is there space if
they're touching well if there's if if
they maintain their surface if the
surface remains intact and doesn't blend
with the other one
then they're not touching it means
ultimately there's space
encapsulating them and you take god's
microscope and you go in there or
telescope whatever and look in there and
you'll see space
and you put them closer together and you
expand that with another microscope and
you see space
and there's space and space and space
and space the only time that space
disappears
is when the two objects
blend
and their surfaces at least at one point
at least in the surface becomes
uh common to both
then they became one object
now they're touching
touch one object touch blending
okay please understand before one of us
dies
okay so here we have
that's touching
touching means that they
blend become one object figure eight in
this case just an example okay
okay and what this fellow is proposing
instead is something like this okay he's
saying they overlap
are they touching well as long as each
uh object maintains its surface it's
surrounded completely by
um
what is it by uh space you can say by
that's nothingness we call space
okay so this is this is where the
problem is okay
okay give me a second here remove all
this stuff
give me a second
okay
okay
so
because of that we
reach
that even in the real world
we have blending not of the ropes not of
the threads
but of the unit of uh mass
which is the atom the
smallest
unit of mass is the hydrogen atom and
here you have a situation where the two
objects blend
okay why because one is drawn into the
other
the threads are blended in that sense
they're not blended what happens the
thread continues from one atom into the
other so in that sense these two objects
have become one the hydrogen molecule is
a is touch
that is touch why because they blended
okay now does that mean that the thread
blended with another no it's the same
thread that now because they're so close
together goes into the other atom
okay so they they they screw into each
other but it's the same thread
okay so again
you have to find out which is the system
and the system here is the atom not the
thread not the rope
and let me repeat that the system that
we're analyzing are the or the systems
are the two atoms okay so the two atoms
are blending not the threads or the rows
the atoms are platinum okay so let's
find out which one is the object we're
talking about the two atoms touching not
about the ropes or the threads touching
rows go through ropes
they don't have the ability to touch
another rope
okay and um
so the father asks he continues
he says the following
and again i hope about these clarify
questions for other people who have
similar
inquiries you know
we made it to the big question good
finally okay how do you pull tangible
objects with intangible objects
i guess he's suggesting you're
insinuating that you have the rope rope
is intangible okay
and he says how do you pull with these
things if they don't touch
well you have to remember that the row
the two threads of the rope right they
go into an atom they form the atom so
it's not like they're connected to the
atom
like something else that's connected
like you know you put a hook there or
something
no what they are is they go into the
form part of the atom
and then on the other side the rope
comes out and goes to another atom and
so on down the line so it's a
train of
uh ropes followed by atoms followed by
rows followed by atoms all one thread
so it's not like it's attached
hooked or whatever
where you say oh if this is intangible
how come it touches
something which is tangible no it's the
thread goes all around the universe
it's one thread
and so ropes convert into atoms
converted into ropes it's a single
system okay
and uh so what happens when one atom
slides along the rope
well the atom doesn't touch the rope the
atom is going to touch another atom like
i showed just a minute ago where it
blends in with another atom but
meanwhile what happens is it slides
along the ropes so here we have an
example which i've put in the past which
is you have the atoms that form your
fingers okay
and i just put one atom per finger
that's all you got there and as the hand
slides towards the ball okay the
ropes that connect the atoms of the ball
to the atoms that form your hand your
fingers right you're sliding your hand
along those ropes
okay and you're not touching the rope
you're do what you're doing is your atom
is sliding through them like a beat on
an abacus
and the ropes are going through because
they're forming part of your atom right
they're going around the electron shell
and the proton
uh dandelion as we call them
and what you're doing is just sliding
through the ropes you're eating into the
rope as you move so you're not touching
the rope and again you gotta identify
what the objects are the objects here
are the atoms not the ropes so you can't
touch the rows but at the same time
are you
pushing or pulling on that
ball
well no what you're doing is sliding
through the ropes okay that's what the
atoms of your body are doing
okay here we have uh another question
related again to all these
let me remove this for a second here
give me a second
uh related to the word object which
destroys their religion as you can see
there at the bottom the definition of
the word object destroys all religions
absolutely and that's what these people
fear and hate oh how can you do this to
us
so he said you said everything you can
draw or imagine has shape
uh
no one i said that everything that is an
object
has shape
and if it has shape
you should not have a problem drawing it
okay let's get it right let's get the
wording right let's understand it
correctly okay so
he says that anything that you can draw
has shape not true because the number
five has shape you can draw it it's not
an object why because it's not the
number five and i'll get that to that in
a second you'll see why okay let's
continue here that means that deltas he
was talking about the delta saying that
it's a physical object as explained by
me must have shape according to you
because you were able to follow my
instructions and draw it yeah i can draw
a delta the letter delta
yeah all i see is just a symbol
you say is that an object
not because i can draw it but because
that thing whatever that little d there
is has shape and i can point to that
you call that a delta yeah whatever that
is it's an object because it has shape
so if you say delta has shape yeah but
that delta has nothing to do with the
delta you explained
because you said that the delta is some
kind of change between two frames and la
la
and that's not an object
if you're going to represent it with a
delta with the let with that symbol
and you're going to call that symbol
delta
that is an object
because it has shape whatever that thing
is like a number five is an object
but see if you say well uh the five
represents blah blah blah blah blah now
they them all bets are off that thing
that you see in front of you that is an
object
you call it five you call it x you you
want to call it the tree you can call it
whatever you want
okay and you say well you drew a five so
it's five an object
no that thing that has shape is an
object not the five the five is
something else
and let me show you why okay
uh very easy to destroy
this fella's
insinuation there okay his argument
here we have it this is his question he
says we now have a more clear oh this
another file but along the same lines i
need to show this first
we now have a more clear revised
definition of object object that which
you can draw or imagine okay
if you don't think that definition is
more clear go and reread
and he says rome hypothesis appendix 5
not all objects are visible or tangible
well the first thing we're going to
mention is that what an object is not
okay an object is not that which you can
point to and an object is not that which
you can draw
what was the definition
you got to stick with the definition you
can't move a single
letter of the definition the definition
is that which has shape
now if it has shape
whatever it is if it has shape you can
point to it and you can draw it and if
you can draw it you certainly can point
to it
it doesn't work in the opposite
direction
it's not because you know i i
point to something that is an object
especially depends on
the concept that represents
and let me show you why i'll give you an
example now that shows you why these
people
are
have mental problems they don't
understand this okay
what do you see there at the bottom uh
well someone would say that's a six
is that a six
or is that an object
and you say well it's the same thing
because that has shape it's a six so
obviously it's an object
well
let me modify it a little bit just so
that you know that we're on the same
wavelength okay here it is okay let's
modify it a little bit is that a six
it's the same object it's just lying
down it's in a different position is
that a six
maybe it's a nine i mean i don't know
and so the question is
the object
is the shape i don't care what
situation it is you can put it upside
down if you want it's still the not just
because it has shape
is that a six
and the answer is no that's not a six
but i thought you said it was a six
right
and uh yeah it's a six over here okay
but not over there
because you're
you're reading too much into it we're
looking at the object that has shape and
if you want to call it a six an x
a tree a rock you can call it whatever
you want
but that doesn't mean that that
represents what we understand by the
word six which is a number which is
counting which is a verb which is a
process
so these two are
separate things different things
okay and with that
i'll see you next time and hopefully i
feel better next